we are live a little bit late welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel and today we are going to be
talking about the star gate and whether
it should be released to the public when
you know new show comes back but for a
moment say hello everybody
hello everybody howdy
consider that music I don't like it
[Music]
gone
so yeah happy Sunday guys it's a bank
holiday weekend for us here in the in
the uks I don't know what it is for you
guys but that basically means I'm
getting very drunk this evening
um as we speak but it's not going to be
t for
veterans
oh that's not so much fun now this is
just getting drunk weekend that's just
like yeah it's spring
let's get pissed yeah I'm not sure why
we have a bank holiday I'm not sure what
it's in in Aid of this time we had one
like a few weeks ago for the Kings
coronation like that made sense but now
we just have we have random ones
throughout the year that we I don't
really know why
it's something to do with spring but God
the God damn it we love it yeah but um
I'm glad everyone's okay and we are
going to be talking about Stargate again
this weekend so obviously we have to do
the normal intro
[Music]
and before we get into this week's topic
we have to do
um the other video that you did the
Stargate news so let's do that because
I've you know Stargate news
[Music]
there isn't any
damn thing
nothing
um
I posted some news on Tick Tock today
that you was posted about three days ago
about San Diego Comic-Con
yeah so basically the news for San Diego
Comic-Con is that there isn't really any
news
so we spoke about it last week that
Amanda Tapping and Richard Dean Anderson
are currently signed on and they're
supposed to be appearing at San Diego
Comic-Con
so we're hoping that that means that's
going to be part of a Stargate big
announcement
um fedcon have you seen some of the
videos from fedcon last week it's
freaking amazing by the way they were
all there they're this big Stargate
thing that they all came curtain oh it
was brilliant and we're trying to find
some videos on it and I'll post them if
I can but um
uh at the moment they're still going to
be at San Diego Comic-Con it's not been
canceled that's as close as I can get to
news that like a no news is good news
kind of situation
um but we'll see we'll see what happens
I think it's gonna all depend on the
industrial action and how far spread it
goes
really
well
if sag strikes they won't be able to
show up
yeah it would be it would be difficult
it would be difficult for them to do if
sound goes on strike as well
um it's quite annoying because we spoke
about the San Diego Comic-Con thing last
week and then
I posted a video on Tick Tock and it
done really done better than the
Stargate News videos that I do every
couple of days
we've got like 35k 45 000 views and then
you voted that video it might not happen
I'm like I'm gonna I'm gonna leave it
for like three or four days and just see
if anything else comes out before I had
you say anything
yeah maybe I should do everything it's
please don't cancel it I don't care I
don't care if you stand up there I know
okay the stand up there and just go it's
happening
but not for a bit calm down everybody I
would take that
um I I rich I'm gonna say Richard Nelson
has lost a crapload away he looks so
good yeah watch him he's got the
MacGyver haircut again yes
he looks way way better than he did
three years ago I'm doing a little bit
of a compilation video of a few of the
um last few Comic Cons he's done
um and I'll throw up late in the week
um and he obviously from about three
years ago he looks way better
um so let's fingers crossed for that so
um yeah he's he's looking good so
um
we're doing a video today about whether
when the new franchise comes back should
the Stargate be released to the public
reveal to the public or should it still
be a secret and we know from the third
um Stargate movie that was supposed to
get made that was supposed to be a rich
team anderson-based Movie that that
straight to DVD movie
um was going to be
the plot was basically going to be about
the Stargate getting revealed to the
public and we also know that in Brad
Wright's script that was
had its head cut off just before um
covid that in that script this target
was going to be revealed to the General
Public
first of all just before we get into the
detail of it what's your instinct yes no
just just a straight yes no shouldn't be
revealed to public yes or no Matt yes
should be revealed
nope
and Harris yes
okay let's see if I by the time we've
finished the discussion whether we've
changed our minds because I
I'm going to go I'll go no then but I
have a good reason why I don't think it
should be
but we'll we'll come back to it so
before we get into that then I put a
poll on the channel
it's at 1.6 000 votes or 1600 votes and
it is in any revivalist Target should
the starget program be revealed to the
public it is 51.49
right percent so it is it is
a 51 in favor of yes that it should be
revealed to the public now that is
dividing or what that is that's even
more dividing than um should we bring
Brad right back oh yeah
I'm no thinking well so that's like
brexit vote
uh so
um another thing before we get started
into the conversation I am sent Brad
Wright the original creator
a quick message
um and he in his gloriousness all hail
Brad right um did respond so
um this is just and I think his opinion
matters a little bit you know we won't
take it too seriously but his opinion
does matter and I can't see it where did
I put it isn't that it
no that's the background
come on Matt where did I put it back
there overlays overlays yeah overlays
thank you so I can ask you a question
I'm doing a live Sunday we're talking
about the Saga program the guy you guys
should love to hear his answer so I just
think there comes a point there's hidden
so much power in technology and science
from a world-facing global climate
change and pandemics becomes morally
indefensible
we're going to rip that apart as we talk
into it but that is Brad Wright's
opinion and you know actually I can't
really argue that because he is the dad
when it comes to Stargate so
Dylan he could say Scott's Stargates are
going to be square now we're just like
yep that's fine
actually the Angels put a device that
changes the shape of a Stargate after a
certain amount of time
[Laughter]
transferred forms into an oblong yeah
all right
um before we get stuck into that I mean
first of all
right the first question I'm going to
ask you guys then and I'll ask I'll ask
Aaron you you can go fishing this one
okay we give technology like the nakoda
reactors to probably block it like every
episode we go to there's some guy living
in a ute on a hill somewhere we're going
to run an accurate and they're like oh
that's lovely thank you very much and
then you know they're powering cities of
them but we are still building coal and
oil and and whatever else you're on
Earth and destroying our own planet
does it make any logical sense
the
at least the technology wouldn't be
revealed for the public
oh I was yeah I
I
think it's in revealing I think a slow
reveal like you know
of uh more and more advanced technology
to the public would be fine just as long
as like it we made it look like it came
from our own research
like we've been working on this it like
call it a conjunction effort with
between military and civilian and
scientific entities and we finally
cracked this
here we go
well you don't even with this mineral
that doesn't exist
there'd be a little bit of you know
we're already in the much of it was in
the middle of a bunch of pre-varication
anyway what's one more little white lie
on that one
they could say they discovered the they
could say they discovered it in like a
chunk of asteroid that fell and then we
learned how to synthesize it
what do you think Harris
uh I mean along those same lines if it's
a slow roll of Technology then it it it
might be easier to appease the public uh
honestly I'd say just rip the Band-Aid
off because we want the cool technology
obviously but it would make more sense
for them to slow roll it out to the
public and
maybe guys under themselves I mean you
know they could put that into a dozen
different narratives uh in different
places you could even put it into like
okay well you be honest with the public
say oh it's in Antarctica but we didn't
know about it until uh climate change or
something like that you know and you
could you could make a dozen different
ways to like make it make sense in a way
to the public without being completely
dishonest uh which might give you like
uh uh I guess less hate from the public
but one way or another the public is
going to freak out about this and uh I
say just rip that Band-Aid off you know
exactly who benefits from the lies at
that point
once that even if the bandage is
slightly peeled and you get a little bit
of Technology we already see all these
different uh corporations and different
people within Stargate just like kind of
running their own way and doing their
own things uh
who's to say how people would react you
know it'd be interesting it would be
I'd say slow is probably better slow is
probably better but rip the Band-Aid off
is
the most sensible
yeah
um United just go to nobody cares but
it's one all yeah we went one little
dance before the game before the live
started so I was a bit like
okay but anyway
Matt what do you think
they I think if they're going to reveal
it like Harrison and Aaron said it would
have to be a slow burn kind of reveal
because if they did it in a different
way if they just said yeah we could we
we have a Stargate we can go to
different planets we have ships we have
this technology we have this we have
this we have this
the political for I'm not I'm not asked
about the public here the political
Fallout of that would be insane to know
that the US government had this
technology
for for a better part of a decade well
now it's nearly a better part of two
decades
um and it
this this will tie into Brad Wright's
comment in a time of like climate change
and all this kind of stuff these
technology would have helped
so then not releasing it
years ago
the political
um
yeah would be
incredible
I mean the thing I have to wonder is is
even remotely logical no matter that
this would still be a secret
I think
the the program itself
came so close to being revealed multiple
times during its tenure that it should
it probably would have there have been
rumors about it because the internet is
a much larger thing now in our society
where people talk about rumors and
as an example
uh there's there's a proper celebrity in
the UK or Phillip Schofield
um there's some things that he's done
but that's been going around on the
internet for a better part of a year
literally everything that's now just
coming out so I reckon something similar
will have happened in in the Stargate
Universe yeah like it's the same with
like Area 51 and all stuff like that
people like research it and they've got
like
you had your Mystery Machine Channel
where you talked about Mysteries and
that there'll be channels like that
dedicated to
is there a Stargate program in the
Stargate Universe
so yeah people will know and people will
be prepared
um
yeah I think I think
majority of people will have the
understanding that something is
happening but they don't know quite know
what
I already argue even it's not even the
Stargate program that's the problem
that to keep a secret the problem is the
how many Starships have we built by this
point
and you know we built four or five three
or fours we'd have three or fives by
this point three or sixes there would be
how many people would have to know about
the Stargate program we'd have off work
off world bases and everything I mean
what we've been invaded a couple of
times
yep keeping a Stargate Secret
Aarons think that that's not really a
big problem but keeping like the
wider program that is spawned from it is
that is that the problem
I don't think the ships is so much of a
problem
because we have
um beaming technology now
those ships never have to land on Earth
again
yeah but they could build on different
planets
okay we have colonies and other planets
um the only reason
um that that rich guy I can't think of
his name
um in season eight or nine uh he became
close to revealing the Stargate program
was because he had satellites looking at
uh Antarctica so it was literally on the
surface of the Earth
it's a lot harder to see them
above us because they've been moving so
quickly with telescopes and things like
that
yeah and we've got cloaks and stuff as
well we could literally hide On the Dark
Side of the Moon like they've done a few
times like I don't think it's much of an
issue
for people on Earth anyway
okay so just thinking about ships and
thinking about all this technology
sorry my British friends but the United
States Air Force has the Stargate and is
the people that are typically building
the vast majority of these ships if you
expose this to the public why wouldn't
the U.S say all right everybody's
joining the U.N right now and we're in
charge
if they reveal it publicly why wouldn't
they do that there's I don't I don't I
don't I mean stop with the political
like Fallout from it and say I know it's
not our ideals we're Mr democracy
National Republic over here America but
if that were to happen we might have to
change our tune and kind of just be like
yeah we know the Fallout that'll happen
so we're just we're taking charge I I
can see that happening just as well
which might put us at a fault with the
other four of the five Great races
because they don't want that kind of
like dictatorial kind of running of a
planet so that could kind of put us at
fault with the furlings per se or
whatever you know
let me walks
um
oh yeah
and it doesn't matter what president
what side or who's in there
they would do it you know like it's I I
think that would be their response to
political Fallout would be like hey yeah
sorry
I mean like who all was on that Council
in the first place us France
Britain Britain China and Russia right
yeah okay so
we why would the French people that
could cause us both the most political
and Military problems are already in are
already mixed up in it with us anyway
so I don't know so much that we'd really
have to take over
um in it to the extent that they knew it
existed but they were kept at arm's
length
to the people of their Nations knowledge
will be enough for them to lose their
minds
China got grounded of their own BC 304
they didn't know Russia did Russia did
and then it got destroyed so the U.S are
the only ones with ships still colonel
shekov
I love that I mean if you want if you
want a whole worldwide um
uh
occurrence of nationalism
you'll get it if you reveal that program
yeah yeah like Don Christopher just
posted
uh Russia had their own gate technically
the gate we have is that gate so yeah
they've still got that political
leverage over us
well possessions
if we say we're taking over they'd lose
their leverage if we literally just say
those words and say yeah we don't we're
not taking your like it's literally
semantics at that point
well if we think about the politics then
because we we live in a slightly
complicated political landscape
particularly over the last decade
and we we left Cold War and we've seen
to have gone back into it it's only like
you know I had like those big Nostalgia
like the 80s and stuff um I'm on telly
since like
stranger things and music and everything
everything was a bit 80s it's like
politics when the 80s were great we
could do whatever we wanted because of
the cold war let's go do that again
um so
genuinely speaking if the Stargate
program was released to the public
would we have to have a different
political reality in the show I think
the point is then is the the Stargate
one of the reasons why we love this so
much because it was always tied to some
sort of reality
would a new show if
you know they say the Stargate is
revealed to the public obviously that's
a big departure from realism but also
politically what they have to completely
rewrite
I think it would be more interesting to
see the political Fallout and see the
relationships being mended and built and
these
um
these legislations and like these
governments like coalitions and
everything forming as a result of this
announcement and the Earth coming
together
that could be its own story and it would
probably be a thing that
um
it will never be it won't be resolved
like within like two or three seasons
it'll be something like that goes on for
it realistically it takes like 100 years
for
for like the whole world to come to come
together really
but that would be such an interesting
plot point that you'd have so many
different stories of
of Russia's not happy that we've got the
BC 307 like above their whatever and
then they're launching their own ships
and they'll be like uh civil wars that
we protest in the in the streets from
the civilians of that country
yeah I I just think it'd be more
interesting
having
I don't know that comment before I put
it up
so I just put a comment up I need to
sworn in it
yeah it would just be more interesting
to see
the
so kind of like how we saw the 3G file
Nation get formed
yeah but on Earth
everyone gets United there's gonna be
some bumps on the road there's gonna be
people who want to take over and
you know up cause a revolution things
like that so would that be more like or
would that be more like Lucian Alliance
no so in an attempt to make a coalition
of governments a United planet
as we should be but we're not because
we're all just sovereign states all
acting and our own self-interests but
literally with with this that we should
have
an attempt to make a coalition of
governments and a United planet
and that playing out would be the most
interesting thing
because there's so much so much so many
things that'll go wrong
yeah well I mean is there any way like
the comment back there that that uh okay
but that's not Stargate is
it's not what we know as Stargate as of
now but if we're being realistic and
like like following the just
technological path that the series has
followed why would we not it's going to
look more like it's not going to look
like Stargate as we have known it it's
gonna look more like Stargate Universe
it's gonna look more like Star Trek I
think it's going to look more like the
expanse everything we're talking about
is if World Government ends up happening
in a certain sense it's going to end up
being like the expanse which in if you
have that higher shora AG Dash Lou I
don't ever remember how to say her name
but she's awesome so come on uh
it'd be awesome uh but I I think we
would look a lot more like the expanse
or at least
this Stargate series could almost look
like a prequel to The expanse in a lot
of ways uh just because it is
how we would Advance technologically
like on the path we've already been
given and the expanse doesn't have like
beaming technology or anything like that
but we'd have like those rail guns and
we'd have things like that you know
etc etc
would it becomes hard sci-fi sorry go
now
oh um I was just gonna say someone
earlier up in the comments uh noted the
fact that um
the people as a mob generally uh are
much less intelligent when you get them
like the more people you get together
the lower the collective IQ gets
um and also with the Revelation that big
you can forget the culture War at the
time because literally everyone is going
to be like what the is the government
been hiding from like he right and left
would unite at least for a while over
something that big
so you'd have you'd have the countries
would be you the uh the populations of
the countries that be United for a while
not with each other country but
their internal political divisions would
disappear at least for a while because
they'd all be so pissed that their
governments were hiding this from
when they release it and everyone still
goes crazy and and then I think there
would be that I want to be at the press
conference when somebody sort of puts
her hand up
to ask a question that sort of says um
has there been any threat to the Earth
during this period that you know we need
to know about and the guy in the podium
still going threat
um Define threat yeah
I have anybody on Earth ever been put at
risk oh well
um
[Music]
what type of risk he comes on stage with
his binder of mass
today no I don't mean today I mean like
at all this week no no not this week
information
something I mean even even if you forget
like a humongous Earth shattering
question like that here's one here's
just a basic one that'll just cause
enough ripples
how much on all these ships
yeah that's a great yep he said what
yeah but without the ships they wouldn't
have been able to defeat the URI if they
didn't defeat the URI everyone would be
all right
they probably doesn't know that though
all they would see is you've been
spending all our tax money and whatever
and all that crap on these ships they
won't care about why yet at least not to
you know because they're not going to be
analyzing at that point in time they're
just going to be reacting and their
first reaction is going to be you could
have been spending that money on this
and this to help this and this and
you're building spaceships have you seen
our schools it would it would be exactly
like that because I'd imagine it would
be
do you remember where I'm not going to
say the c word but you know that
pandemic we had Oh I thought you were
saying see you next Tuesday no no you
remember that pandemic we had and as
soon as the news broke basically the
entire world came together in in a way
and everyone went into like their into
their lockdowns and everyone in the
country was just like okay yeah we're
going in top down we're going to follow
the guidance we're going to follow what
the government says and then three
months in six months in whatever
people started to think and they're like
do we really want to be here and then
people started like becoming like
deniers
divided as normal
people everything divided everyone had
their own opinions and people still have
their own opinions on it it would be
exactly the same if the program was
released to the public like it's a
global it's a global event everyone in
the world would probably play
okay and then like three four months to
online they were like
getting up and did it it was it's just a
hoax it's well aliens the government did
admit aliens exist basically during the
pandemic and no one care so um
thank you for all that's interesting
thank you so much the premises perceived
would be the best way for the public and
rather let Earth deal with its own
Fallout nestige off-world looking for a
cure thank you very much for your
comment and really appreciate that I
have seen many messages about Stargate
Crusade idea but I didn't read them
because I'm trying to talk it sorry
um
right so the one thing I was thinking
about was sort of like religion and
things like that as well if this was
released to the public then
how long do you think it would take the
Catholics to stop running around and
screaming ah
for I'm thinking six to seven years
and they might stop running around going
ah never mind the more Orthodox
religions of the world
it would put into question some of the
more contemporary religions but I think
I think it was always a good idea that
they never
um they never delved into like
Christianity and Catholicism
yeah there's no Jesus my name isn't
Jesus
Christ
we told you all your gods were crap we
have the only one they'd be having a
party in the Vatican and in Georgia
and you know all over the place really
Jesus was an ancient
cheese or whatever but I I would
actually argue that in the show the
ancients
were Christians the Christianity
it wasn't particularly subtle though was
it
um so yeah maybe
um Jesus is an ancient that's what I'm
saying yeah I just think that there's a
lot of religious people that would be it
was
is Ascension closer to Christianity or
is that closer to like a Buddhism or a
taoism or something
they always add more strong links with
Buddhism as they are sort of ideology
that didn't they to be fair it was more
spiritual than religion to before
Buddhism is the belief that you're going
to be reincarnated though so I don't
think it would be Buddhism
moving to a higher plane is is yeah
except Christianity calls their higher
plane heaven
yeah
those are the ascended in their pure
energy form flying around could easily
be called an angel
yeah they look like an angel when they
fly around legit so I would I would I
would call it a mix but like you said
Jay I would say it leans more towards
the Eastern side of it but there's
definitely Western Christianity in it
too
okay so if you were gonna a couple of
questions in first of all when the new
series comes to us and I'm so sorry
about my wife I know I keep slowing down
but when it comes to the show being
released do we want to either see that
it was released to the public in the 15
years previous or
do we want it released to the public
during the initial parts of the show
coming back
I'd like to see it released
when we can see it I'd like to see it
play out
okay just because the the political and
the public like Fallout would be so
insane that there'd be so many really
cool storylines that will come from it
yeah it needs we need to see it it's not
it's not worthy of a um a flashback kind
of thing it's too big of an event too
big in it yeah
what do you think huh
um
it really depends on what kind of show
you want um someone I can't remember who
earlier in the comments mentioned that
uh
there's a chance that the show would
shift away from like way away
from you know what it used to be and
they'd have to spend way too much time
dealing with political Fallout and a lot
less time having fun flying around the
planets in June so
um
I I honestly think
well again it depends on what kind of
show you're on if you really want to
delve into that then you know have it
happen in the first two episodes
um if you just want to get back to the
normal business of Stargate it needs to
happen before the show starts yeah
cars
uh kind of along those same lines I I'd
love to see the
the the the the Fallout and everything
just from
showing the public the Stargate and all
this stuff but
also
it'd be nice to start the series as is
get back into that Stargate kind of feel
that that it might not be super hard
sci-fi like what we've been talking
about but it's close enough at this
point where okay we know what we're
getting when we jump into it
and I know prequels aren't your favorite
thing in the world but that does allow
them to do maybe not a prequel series
but they could do a prequel mini series
and try to do like real same thing like
if they want to bring back sg1 SGA kind
of more yeah it's hard sci-fi but it's a
little goofy it's a little fun we're
having a good time it's not so like
strong uh drama like Stargate Universe
tends to be even though I'm only three
episodes that's that's the general
consistence I get you know uh
so I I would think they might want to
take that route again but if they want
to go that Stargate Universe route and
bring that more uh dramatic kind of feel
back to it why not hire somebody like
the Chernobyl guy that's doing last of
us you know let them do another season
or two of that and then do a mini series
that's a prequel about the political
Fallout on Earth and
have just like eight episodes that
describe everything something like that
I don't know
I got an idea yeah well how about we
have something in the movie do we think
there's gonna be a cinematic movie first
that there's basically it's so big
whatever happens in the movie is so big
an effect on you know on a worldwide
scale sort of thing that that is the
what then forces them to release the
Stargate you know like Anubis actually
comes down and hovers over Pig in New
York and then everyone sort of goes ah
ascended form or in a ship
oh no no just floating there in his
cloak
like I I was thinking something
I never understood similar to that
except instead of the reveal being
forced
they choose to reveal it at the
beginning of the movie spend like you
know 10 or 15 minutes on the Fallout and
then something huge happens to cause the
world to go
okay we don't care if they're hiding it
anymore thank you for saving our ass
that's kind of where I think that could
be that could be handled like that in
the movie before we even get into the
series and then the series can just
start
we into the gate we go
I never understood what you know with
Anubis how he when he was about to take
out to invade Earth he projected himself
into the White House why didn't he
project himself into like
I don't know what what is a Public
Square that everyone goes to in America
like
Taylor Swift
Just somewhere public or multiple people
don't like Fallen did in the
Transformers movie and just like hack
satellites and broadcast himself on
every signal on the planet
yeah
that makes sense just because Goulds or
Goulds and whether he's half ascended it
or not he's still a good old and they
are prideful little
things you know uh so I would think he'd
be like let me go straight to the leader
he'd literally be the alien going take
me to your leader because that's just
what gold would do you know
yeah but I think I think he would have
he it would have made more sense for him
to broadcast himself or at least project
himself to multiple locations because
then he could incite more fear and
that's what he wanted he wanted people
to be scared of him
yeah but if you got the US president I I
mean I don't know how much he knows
about Earth politics or whatever but if
you have the US president scared that
the world's about to explode he has a
couple phone calls to make real quick
and that same thing happens uh
yeah but then it's just hearsay oh this
this guy just appeared in my in my
office what does he look like oh he's
just wearing a black clothes what do
they know about the Stargate bro if even
if you only called Britain France Russia
and China like that might be the only
four or five countries you call it first
but
um
see what would you it's a what what does
he look like kind of looks like my
teenage son
yeah
older like so narcissist narcissist
assistant narcissistic and
megalomaniacal
and they they live they rule on fear so
I for me I think it would have been a
better idea to go the Fallen route and
just like hack everything and
scare the entire planet all at once
yeah yeah
I I just wonder if if they if they do
this as part of the new series or thing
and it actually gets announced
as part of the plot the initial plot so
if something happens and it has to be
announced because of that I think we
then start getting into a lot of
potentially episodes about politics and
about how people react and about
the economy crashing and I just think
a lot of boring crap I just wonder
whether it might be more interesting if
this happened a decade ago and that's
where the show starts and then we do get
the odd little
flashbacky bit
that tells us about maybe how it
happened right would be maybe more
interesting that they could pick and
choose
but also from a more interesting show
we're 10 years down the line
we've already come together we've
already and then they can do little bits
about you know a few of the problems
along the way and they can
scoot back to it not as a prequel
because prequels suck
but um unless they do anything
some prequels for Stargate would be
amazing and you know it I would do an
ancients
when we did our little Series where we
did like four or five videos didn't we
talked about what this is like four or
five series we want to see this is what
we'd want to see we did say and like the
third or fourth season we won a prequel
Stargate Atlantis prequel uh you know or
the launches and then in the background
you can see like the destiny being built
or something how cool would that be
gonna throw a window
um how about something covering when the
Ancients and the gold first run into
each other
that was our plot basically about where
the feelings came into it that the
furlings kind of created the gold
and that's why they were then they so
they were like a part of The Pavilions
was kind of banished and then the whole
plot was the feelings coming back and
that's why they were kind of the
villains
um so we sort of dealt with that at the
entrance ever interact with the gold I
don't think they did no because they
were
um because they were like 10. yeah
that's right
before the gold even got here anyway
right yeah yeah I think the last time we
saw the gold was at the Ancients was the
50 000 years ago I'm gonna have to
double check my uh
I think you know but um
they were they were around in medieval
times so around the time of like King
Arthur Merlin and that
so maybe they would because that was
after the no I think that was just
almost the Ancients had gone then that
was just Merlin coming back wasn't it
sometimes the Ancients would yeah take
human form
yeah well they did do a lot of expansion
throughout the Galaxy too obviously
because yeah
they ran into the race in Pegasus why
wouldn't they uh
well they correctly at least maybe just
experience them just a little bit and
then be like yeah no and then you know
take off and
go elsewhere in the Galaxy that the gold
haven't gotten to yet
are we at risk though that when this
happens and we've done a couple of
videos talking about this in the past to
be fair but is this going to be
Star Trek instead of Stargate
is that a problem
I think it's gonna look more like the
expanse
yeah
it's like Star Trek because it's still
going to be somewhat realistic and
grounded in reality it's just gonna be
this is a more idealistic version of our
current reality where we have these
Technologies and these ships and these
things are happening
and I think the target always was that
really it was a more idealistic version
of the reality we already lived in
where we have this technology to go to
other planets and cure a disease that
come through from a ascended being
like
talk about the pandemic again
we could have really done with uh with
that cure
well we know medically we had lots of
Technology access and but maybe then
that's how we got a vaccine so quick
didn't take very long
yeah
so
you know maybe that the whole pandemic
was caused by something from
otherworldly and uh yeah
hey any excuse for Miranda background to
be back and and yes
so maybe yeah maybe it's an expanse feel
rather than Star Trek and which I could
live with because I don't want to know
the Star Trek series I want Stargate and
Stargate is different
the only thing trekky about it is is
just the Asgard beam that's it I I don't
see any other really
big comparison besides that really
something of the global piece is very
good is very rotten Berry like the whole
the whole yeah that's how Earth is at
the time of the Federation
yeah I think they would probably make
reference to to Star Trek if they were
going to go down the unification of the
entire planet
and then Jack would be like and then we
can get the Enterprise
like slap him or something
one goofball scientist that showed up in
a couple episodes was talking about
ever you know talking about worshiping
at the altar of Roddenberry so there's
been a few directions Dr Lee yeah
yeah
oh yeah in the other guys doesn't he
oh well let's have a think about then if
it is released to the public what
so if we're still that okay it would
massively affect the planet the planet
would be very different how would
actually though affect the show
first of all let's see what what's
actually core to Stargate what to
Stargate what a new Stargate show need
to have in it for us to go yeah this is
still Stargate it's not oh
sci-fi you know it's not in the
expression first of all I'd throw in
it's got to have the humor it's Target
the universe lacked for me
but Atlantis in sg1 definitely had would
you guys agree with that it's it's yeah
we need that yeah it needs to be fine
you need to have some sort of humor you
need to have a quirky like leader or
main character who's not afraid to like
just take the piss when it's like
completely unnecessary because it makes
it it just breaks attention and it's
yeah
I mean they they're they can eat they
can make the show overall more serious
but
if if as long as they inject the humor
in the right places that's fine it's
like Marvel used to know how to do that
yeah well that's the scariest thing I
don't want them to try to Marvel it with
humor I I would rather them take it
seriously and give us a Sci-Fi show than
try to Marvel it a thousand percent I
I'd say as much as I I mean Stargate is
humorous and that's one of my favorite
aspects about it but I would rather them
go hardcore sci-fi and screw the humor
instead of them being like let me add
this in here and add this in here and
quip here here here here here and here
and it's just it's it overwhelms you so
fast and I feel like Stark if that
happens Stargate will not come back as a
successful show because it's just gonna
be lost in the Zeitgeist everything else
I think it needs to be its own thing
for the sake of it is exactly and humor
is not Marvel humor it's it's it's kind
of the precursor to it in a lot of ways
but it's definitely not the same humor
and I think if we if Stargate even
inches into that thing it could it could
just go put so fast because we're so
over it I mean Guardians is great but
like every other thing that Marvel's put
out in the last two three years is just
yeah the problem
that's not getting any better Gardens
wasn't supposed to work the first Garden
is the Galaxy movie shouldn't and it and
it did and it was probably one of the
most popular Marvel movies done and then
Ragnarok was funny and it basically
saved the Thor movies and then they
thought well let's do that and they had
to start Foster I always think the thing
was Stargate though was that it was
almost like I've said Superman and stuff
that was a realistic humor that there's
always going to be whenever something is
stressful and maybe it's an English
thing I don't know but whenever
something's really stressful there's
already some guy in the background
taking the piss out of it so we're all
gonna die are we and then do the little
Benny Hill again the best example I've
got for the humor in Stargate is when
ball projects himself into the gate room
and requests help for the replicator
threat in the galaxy and he was like
Jack Jack comes along and he's like well
maybe we could just wait because then
you'll be dead and we'll be glad like
it's just like
he's taking the piss but it it fits the
situation it makes sense yeah
exactly it's it's humor that fits rather
than trying to force it I don't want
them to think the Stargate serious I was
watching the talking uh Richard Johnson
talking about this today and he was sort
of saying he he from day one he wanted
O'Neill to be
sarcastic and funny and to be more like
him because that's how he is he takes
and a lot of the jokes and things were
ad-libbed a lot of time and they the
thing and then they would go I think
O'Neil would take be sarcastic and say
something like this
um
I I just think that's what the because
the ACT just sort of went this feels
right for my character to say that
rather than what's the joke this week
and a lot of Marvel to me feels like
they're like okay we've got a joke
we think it's very funny how do we build
a scene around it
and it's sort of like no that's not
you're supposed to do the story first
and then if something occurs to you to
be funny
yeah I'll do it like like I said the
humor's got to be organic it can't it
can't it can't be shoehorn well
if you want a good story no matter what
format you're putting in it has to be an
organic story you just can't
crowbar in whatever you want to and like
a little spot here and there because
something that obvious will stand out I
mean just look it's Marvel spent the
last two or three years crowbarring and
stuff Star Wars has spent the last
10 years almost or no yeah when did the
first one come out 15 so yeah almost 10
years curl barring stuff in instead of
concentrating on story first so I mean
that's that's just been the big problem
in all the big IPS lately anyway too
much crowbarring not enough real
story based writing
so if we have to compare just for
comparison's sake would y'all say
no Marvel humor but Big Bang Theory
humor
no yeah
well all their humor makes sense and
it's it's it's comical and actually like
tends to be like you know half the time
the funny characters in Stargate are the
smartest characters they're just kind of
making light of this thing as a laugh
track to it
the tone of the human not obviously as
much of it yeah
but with that type of tone I kind of get
that it's that they were but there's a
lot of like pop references and stuff
like that in Big Bang Theory which we
don't want that but there's a lot of Pop
references
yeah that's what Stargate was actually I
was just gonna say Richard Anderson
when he comes in they're about to launch
the Prometheus and he said and he says
you know like ah they they shut down my
my plan and Samsung we can't call it the
Enterprise and it's like um yeah I know
but you know and then all the MacGyver
references
they never went behind the fourth wall
did they never we never saw behind the
fourth wall but we peeked through the
curtains once or twice and I like that
because it was like all of Stargate
though and I wonder if you guys think of
this that the humor was subtle a lot of
the action was relatively subtle there
was they never ever shoved anything down
your throat with star okay and maybe
that's one of the reasons why we loved
it so much
yeah I think the humor
from sg1 largely it comes largely from
Jack but then it's it's Jack's
relationship with like tilk and his cult
the cultural differences between us and
tilk and then making like making jokes
out of tilk and then making jokes with
Daniel
about being a nerd are being a geek and
more stuff like that and it's it's the
relationships I think that make the
humor the same with Atlantis Shepard
isn't Jack but he is still funny
because of his relationship with Rodney
I think yeah and then to a certain
extent with Ronan as well because Ronin
is the outsider
um
yeah
it's literally the best street man in
history
but he was more he was funny as it come
along and that but I love when they took
them most like he would he would tell a
Jaffa joke every so often and and things
like that
um so we saw him being but but yeah he
was a straight man and but Ronan was
supposed to be the straight man but I
think they then realized that actually
um he's such a brilliant actor and such
he's actually a very comedic actor
um that he he got funny but the thing I
always liked
I think what you're talking about there
is it there was the relationships
between some of the actors and it was
like they were best friends and there's
that old joke isn't there because if you
if you come across a friend unconscious
on the floor you might check if he's
okay maybe phone an ambulance if you
find your best friend on the floor
unconscious you draw a penis on his head
then check it out and then maybe throw
in an ambulance
um you know what I mean it's and that's
the sort of thing that that's again I
don't know if it's an American thing I
don't know if it's more of a British
thing but I I genuinely remember my mate
got so drunk on summer uh we were in
magalov and he was so drunk that he was
passed out on a beach so we got the
suntan lotion into her penis on his back
and Sun tail lotion
um and that was the funniest thing in
the world he used it to pull women
it was just like that's a that's an
actual that's that's to scale
it's horrible and you you've turned it
against us
managed yeah you managed to use it again
but that's what that's I think that's
and that was the sort of the thing I
think I don't know if it's because Brad
writes Canadian and that's maybe because
I think Canadian humor is a little bit
more like but you guys tell me what what
do you think is that
is that human
does it feel real to you guys
I'll tell you an example when they find
the personal Shield technology and
um and I think it pushed his McKay off
the off the top of the thing you see him
fall and he gets it and Weaver comes at
Michigan's well thank God you didn't
shoot him and they're going
yeah I did that no no he goes what else
did you do and then and then Shepard
just looks and goes I shot him
perfect
um that feels really real to I think
something for us yeah is it for you guys
oh yeah no I mean well I'm I'm a fan of
British humor anyway like I actually
just watched uh what's his name Carr the
other night I can't remember his first
name Jason Jimmy Carter I just watched
him on Netflix the other night fuse with
Alan Carr
there's a lot of us who appreciate the
uh the more dry witty style of the
British humor so you know some something
like that would still fit perfectly in
Stargate
I think they did they did quite well
um
considering it was a show for America
and I know
some a lot a lot of America don't
understand sarcasm
they put sarcasm in it and it worked
let's say generally generally yeah
generally I'm not you you two probably
do I hope you do anyway because I'm
quite sarcastic no
um I've been working on sarcasm most of
my life and I still haven't quite gotten
there yet
in that category
it's a very traditionally very British
thing and it doesn't translate well
but
it does in Stargate it works
yeah I'm not trying to be offensive to
you oh no I mean at least for me it
helps when you get really just a little
bit yeah
jading leads to sarcasm
yeah yeah sarcasm is like my second
language so I think that that's reduced
I I did a job interview recently I had
to do an application form I've got
another year ago now but just just speak
any second languages and I put sarcasm
thinking that is very funny and they
sent the form back to me
they can't say anything about it because
it's a real religion yeah well I'd
already they'd already given me the job
and then sent me the form so of course I
was going to take the piss on the form
there was no there was there was no
motivation for me to not take the piss
on the phone
so don't offer me the job first maybe
yes
um
but if they well say they're for now
then if they didn't
so I think I sort of agreed haven't we
did if they don't reveal it to the
public
we'd get a show that we love but would
it make any sense
if they did if it's still a secret could
they keep it a secret for long but they
have to reveal it at some point
it was always something that has to it
would have it would have happened
eventually and I think it needs to be
something that
maybe initially it's how we how we left
uh how we left off kind of thing is it
still a secret and they're still going
through again it's all doing these
missions but then something happens and
they have to have to announce it
essentially it has it has to become
public knowledge at some point but I
just don't think it has to be something
that already happened I think we need to
see it play out
guys
is it inevitable I think it's an animal
there's there's no if stands or butts
around it it's going to pop out it's
it's I mean literally I mean I just
started SGU like we just said
the daughter of a senator knows about it
and his wife in the first third or
second third episode whatever is going
around saying like oh if my daughter
dies too I'm gonna go spout this out to
the world I'm assuming bad things happen
to her don't don't spoil me of course
but you you can't start going around
saying that kind of things especially to
a government agent in your house like
if Senators families know about it and
because Senators families don't know
about half their freaking things they
don't know about a tenth of the things
they do on a day-to-day basis why would
they know about the Stargate
so if if their families know about it
and heard and the Senator's daughter is
the one like putting some certain things
together I forgot exactly what she did
to put together for uh
their their trip off world or whatever
but she was part of that and and if a
senator's daughters making decisions
like that of course maybe if she was
part of the government but they don't
say that so she's just part of
the general public why would she you
talk about Chloe yes I don't want to
ruin Stargate Universe for you Paris by
the way mate but by the end of it
they're all fine don't worry okay so
it's all it's all tied up in a nice
little game he's already seen the first
episode he knows he knows
because that's what we all keep talking
about I know they're never saved
walked through and saves them with the
book of origin yep that makes sense
[Laughter]
they're all they're absolutely there was
a good comment earlier what would we do
about other aurai ships and stuff
ancient Jesus walks through actually
it's ancients
[Laughter]
flowing hair
um yeah walking walking on water is is
is just a metaphor for walking through a
Stargate
oh my God
Jesus was just puddle jumping
God
and um a 304 powered by
um a zpm only takes three days to get to
Atlantis and Jesus died for three days
and then came back
he just ascended and was like all right
this isn't too much I'll come back it
takes three days to ascend I've made my
camera go all nuts
there we go and yeah that's um there's
there's uh there's so much there I would
certainly think this replicators
probably come into it somehow as well
but anyway we'll leave it
um so I was gonna ask you the
replicators were just the disciples
coming off of Jesus he was the first
replicator Yeah
you mentioned the aura ships where
they've gone I can't remember in Canon
they were powered by the um the prior
staff so once they stop believing in
origin they would have just been
deactivated
okay because they're a power I think
that was the question yeah I don't think
they had any control panels today it was
literally mind control
uh the the prize the ships would just be
sat there floating dead yeah until
someone retro fits it I I I watched it a
couple months ago so it's bad that I
can't remember but didn't Daniel and
Vala fly one very shortly did they have
control over that or uh uh prior at the
moment though that's what I can't
remember
that point wasn't he
Daniel was a prior right then okay okay
okay okay okay okay
let's just like it's quite difficult to
remember the details of 10 seasons of 24
episodes of 240 episodes of sci-fi on it
really specially I finished that in two
seasons of Atlantis later and three
episodes of Stargate Universe look like
it's a lot going on
I I did a video last week about this BC
and I got the math wrong which really
annoyed me I was so careful and I still
got maths Wrong by a factor of 10. I
said before me first
should have done I put it on Facebook
it's nobody but what I did was I did
three billion with nine zeros and then
proceeded to only do eight on the
calculator like a tit but anyway
um so
um you could get there in five years but
actually a BC 304 would take 50 years to
get there and everybody has said
Atlantis Wormhole Drive
and Wormhole drive and I'm like you need
to go and watch the episode again
and then come back to me and tell me
that it can be a wormhole Drive
you see if they if they manage to fix it
and because if it's just a one and done
kind of thing if they manage to fix it
they could literally program it get
enough power and go directly to Destiny
and then fix it again to come back
use the power source that they've got
pull it into Destiny to go through the
game a couple of problems the Pegasus
Galaxy is only three million miles away
the destiny is at least three billion
light years away right it's a factor of
a million times five you just put
another zero in into the zpm converter
just remember to do what I forgot to do
the other thing is what did Sam say
about them being able to take the
Atlantis back to
Pegasus
she said do it next Tuesday no she
didn't she did not say anything
she said it was that it had blown the
system and it burned it out and they
didn't there was no chance of repairing
it they didn't even know what most of
the parts were called never mind I have
to fix them but it's 20 years later they
might know now and the Ancients couldn't
figure out how to get the damn thing to
work properly
see I think the answer lies in the
Asgard call because the Asgard
mysteriously so it used to take us
like weeks and weeks and weeks ago from
one side of the galaxy to the other
right and then the Asgard come along and
they can travel from Ida to the Milky
Way in a matter of hours they definitely
have a wormhole Drive
well and if they don't if they don't
which it doesn't seem like they did they
they probably were there's something
close isn't it yeah
in the world and if we have their
technology right now why is this why why
would we not have reverse engineered
something to like
at least help our understanding of more
ancient things and stuff like that
because you know the Asgard we're doing
research for the Ancients just as much
as we were I mean they were friends with
them way back when you know so they knew
their capabilities to a degree yeah they
said they'd barely scratched the surface
of the um ancient repository ancient
technology yeah
the Ancients were way ahead of the house
God
um at that point but yeah hey that's it
I gotta remember that hyperspace
technology was much much better than
what the Gold World had when we first
saw them they were they were they were
teal so they would take at least a year
for them to for a profits to attack
Earth and by the end of sg1 it only took
three or four minutes to get from
but anyway okay so after our long
conversation let's go back to our
initial question should the show be
um it should it be revealed should the
secret be revealed at the start of the
show Matthew you said yes do you stand
by that yeah maybe not the very start to
show maybe like the second episode or
something but yeah but the the initial
thing should be about to start the show
yeah Aaron if you changed your mind you
said no you don't want it to be you
still want it to be secret
yeah or at least at the beginning of the
show I mean like you were talking about
a little while ago before we diverged
into the Ori stuff it is in this age in
the information age inevitable that
people will find out
there's going to be some kind of trail
for them to follow
um if if they want to reveal it in the
show I would actually make
um an earth-based through line while
people are out adventuring kind of go
back and forth
um addressing how it got found out in
the first place
you know what I'm saying like you know
you got the you got your team out here
bouncing around and then occasionally
you pop back onto Earth where you've got
some seriously good investigative
reporter or whatever kind of like the uh
that one news lady that figured out the
first ship
back in uh to sg1 and then you can make
that like a three or four episode
through plotline and then have have it
come out in the public like you know
what are they doing I think in 10
episodes like episode four or five let
me explain this so if
okay I'll ask all four of you this
breathing on the forefoot
um
if it leaked
don't you think that our governments are
good enough that they will
use social media blah blah blah to make
it mocked and I would say you could use
the UFO experience a lot of people
believe that UFOs were visiting the
Earth there's a lot of evidence the
Pentagon during the pandemic actually
said we've got these three videos and we
don't know what they are basically
admitting they were UFOs
and 95 of people still don't believe it
don't care or it's just mocked which
becomes a joke so nobody cares and a lot
of people in UFO Community say that's on
purpose
wouldn't
the saying be done that if stuff leaked
about the SGC they would just
yeah because they they they they did
that to an extent with sg1 anyway with
top of my head worth more extreme
plausible deniability that kind of thing
yeah
um
yeah it would it would happen like that
but but I think they should have
something an event that would make it
completely undeniable you could not
cover it up
so like you said Anubis floating
floating above the planet
but no maybe like an actual spaceship
like or or loads of them kind of like
Independence Day where they where they
all kind of hover over
like yeah all of the continents it'd be
essentially like that
so Matt's saying bring raw and Emery
back
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm not having that that's something
that makes me want to kick him off the
channel
obviously the government would try and
keep it under wraps and you know do
everything they possibly could to make
this person look stupid and you know
maybe even hit him with the taxi
um
but uh
also I think there's so so many spots on
the internet that you know you could
just disseminate this the information
you have all over the place and if it's
good enough and if enough people buy it
it will gain momentum
to the point where it will become
undeniable especially if they add like
and it doesn't even have to be an
invasion per se or like a big old Anubis
ship floating
say I don't know someone messes up
something and you know something
explodes that no other explanation in
like a weird ass spot that no other
explanation is possible
you know I mean they can't say you can't
say a nuke went off a quarter mile from
a town in Iowa you know because
that would there would be no evidence of
any nuke anything going on there so
I mean like they're maybe they're
building a ship underground and someone
hit the wrong button and that explodes
you know something along those lines
um I I don't I don't go the leak
I don't I don't agree with that I just
think I just think our governments are
too good at spinning stuff I think the
only way this happens if one sides they
want to
um or two
um they've got no choice because if
something happens something like you
said Aaron and something happens they
just cannot deny but could you actually
just anybody actually hand on heart
think the government if this was real
which obviously is nice but the
government would voluntarily release
this unless they've happened to hell no
no it would only be if they had to but
absolutely had to I just think all the
stuff they're doing right now that they
wouldn't ever talk about unless they
were forced to
um I mean they could like you said like
we said that's not they could say that
somebody invented and that could the
reactor or something else and stuff that
can actually help us
um they don't ever have to say it came
from a Stargate or aliens go down the
menu blinded from an asteroid they did
the same they did the same thing in id4
remember they were talking how they got
like cell phones and all that kind of
crap off the one ship that they uh that
they were hanging on to yeah I don't
that's actually where I stole the idea
from honestly
they're like the Men in Black how they
do it oh we got VCR technology or oh the
viagrins have just released a new pill
but yeah
yeah
really no I I would agree with you guys
I just think I just think it would have
to be that something would have to
happen but that could make a very good
and very interesting initial storyline
um
yeah but one of the things that
considering politics
in the world today and we've already
said that okay we think this is gonna
have to divert away from reality which
is going to be less Target than we'd
like but it's gonna have to do the
restroom reality but
at the end of when the SGU thing
happened and you know all these people
went through and there's a massive
disaster the planet exploded there's the
conflict resolution Alliance and all
this is going on the goal rules are gone
the replicators are gone
politics in America maybe went a little
bit more for I always forget it's
right-wing or left wing I always forget
which way around is something's left
wing and but it went more that way left
things Progressive right-wing's
conservative
oh let's go right wingman so it's going
very right wing
um making like whoa over that way would
the Stargate program even still be a
thing or would we as a nation maybe have
turned ins you know become insulated you
know would we say actually turn off the
Stargate program any Starships there
there to defend the Earth
done
and that's maybe where the new series
kicks off
um that could be interesting
but I don't know
with politics being involved at all like
I mean who's who's to say somebody like
Russia doesn't like demand the gate back
and then the us just like literally says
no uh
yeah I mean we're like
I don't know with politics involved I I
feel like the the US tends to
obviously not not win out or or find a
way to put themselves in charge but no
matter what with the Stargate involved
they will find a way to put themselves
in charge I I just kind of feel like
that
these other nations have ships
and we have beaming technology what if
like France or Russia or China just just
went to another planet
whack to be a beaming locator onto a
Stargate took it back to Earth and
they're all fighting for control over
who who is the dominant
um gate on Earth because
it will be one of them it can't be all
of them at once
huh how would they do that without a
ship
they have no they have ships that's what
I'm saying they do now well they must do
it's been 10 years
Russia had a [__] why wouldn't the rest
of them well the Russia only got one
ship after eight or nine years of doing
things yeah I mean it's been 10 years
that's what I'm saying the people that
are in the know what if they
they now have ships and they've just
decided we got this ship now let's just
go Nick a Stargate we don't need
America's
uh approval anymore we can just Nick our
own Stargate and start our own program
it could happen yes but that's it's
still a big if I don't I'm just not
convinced any other countries have ships
I don't I don't know why they would have
the technology to do that because the US
helped Russia build that ship they they
essentially gifted Russia that ship and
then Russia didn't have enough time to
study it they definitely didn't have
enough time to study it no no
the relationship blew up maybe they made
him a new one
Maybe
I don't know
there's a lot there's a lot of ifs and
maybes in this but it's a possibility
I'll say this
um traditionally the conservative side
of uh the American politics is
pro-military
so if you honestly where they're
shutting where they're shuttering the
gate you'd you would need a more uh
you'd need a more left-wing government
in power
because a concern uh again this is
traditional you know obviously there's
room to move inside both um
ideologies but traditionally the
right-wing ideology is much more
pro-military so if a right-wing
Administration was in charge they they'd
be
all about well for the most part trying
to make as many weapons as they could
out of it
rather than you know being um
well contributing to society they'd just
be all about okay we're going to prepare
for literally anything we can think of
I'll put it all in this little budget
over here that no one really gets to see
the lines of
which is basically what they've been
doing the whole time anyway
but if anything you'd seen expand to the
Stargate program under a conservative uh
Administration
so I mean obviously we're talking right
or left or whatever it may be with
within retrospective politics and
whatever Nation on this planet
essentially uh
but
I mean like like Muggles just said in
here I'd rather see a moderate
government what if it's just a normal
Central I guess normal central
government Centrist kind of government
America
[Music]
every week you say something was stupid
Harris
sensible thoughtful government
well I didn't say it was realistic 100
but if you got to change reality just a
little bit I mean if you want that kind
of government you could always make it
Stargate Scandinavia they're pretty
chill up over there
Stargate The West Wing they were pretty
moderate
yeah that was fantasy but no brilliant
yeah all right Sorkin wrote the hell out
of that show oh this is great I'm
watching it again at the moment I'm
freezing sorry I'm watching did you guys
ever catch his um did you guys ever
catch The Newsroom his cable exclusive
show that he put out like
around 2010
guy was amazing in that the first couple
of episodes are just incredible
um now that was a great show I love that
yeah what's his name
it's one of the bridges uh yeah Jeff
Bridges was just just
let's actually do the news
um the Jeff that's actually from
Michigan isn't Bridges is the one that
was the bad guy in Iron Man one right
okay so this is Jeff
yes
Jeff Daniels thank you Tommy
um as well but yeah that was a great
show because I just looked like I said
they just went let's let's stop doing
news shouldn't be entertainment let's
actually do the news and that's what the
show is shame we got canceled when it
did to be honest because it's a
fantastic show first place that show
yeah are you seeing um the one chicken
as well is that she then did
um she's very pretty
talking about
exclusively one that played psylocke in
uh X-Men apocalypse
yes
she's also in that Predator movie that
was almost good but not quite yeah you
engaged Aaron Rodgers for a little bit
yep well I love her very much
um every every episode of this recently
has been going to be coming on and
drooling over some
person I think I need to have considered
that maybe I shouldn't talk about these
things so publicly yeah
oh well too late now guys I think we've
talked the crap out of that so
um I can't remember what we decided but
um I don't think we actually decided
anything I think we're literally half
half were you yes or no at the end of
the day
I think that's why the series should
start I think I'm a map that I think
that's where it should start with it
being revealed
but I don't mind if it's revealed in the
interim as long as we then still get to
see what happened at some point somehow
but I'm okay my just worry is I don't
want Star Trek or the expanse I want
Stargate yes and that's my concern
and it's got to be so whoever does it
has got to be very clever but just like
Brad Wright said if you go back to right
and start the video
at what point does it just become stupid
that it's not been revealed
you know at what point do you just go
this actually isn't believable anymore
all right it was believable for 10 years
June sg1 but at this point it's not
believable anymore and it's getting
silly that it's not been revealed yeah
the planet is with suffering from global
warming or power we've just gone through
a power crisis where you know our
electricity bills tripled in a couple of
months and the economies at what point
sense anymore that at least some of the
technology wouldn't be coming through
even if like they don't mention it went
cold for what like a week two years ago
Texas didn't have enough power to in
Texas is more well uh uh infrastructure
wise based than most other countries in
or states in the US we didn't have
enough power then to to get through a
winner
would have been very useful then after
the generators have been wonderfully
useful then
yeah but
yeah well mughals has just asked the
question now this is going to be going
in the next 10-15 minutes of my life but
we're going to do this anyway screw it
well we are completely starting the
series over again or we start like the
Next Generation
I don't think it can if you use the Star
Trek analogy of the Next Generation so
they just were on a better ship
100 years in the future but actually the
show had the same
basically structure format as the
original series go and explore and blah
blah you can't do that with Stargate
because you can't have the same format
if it's
um if the Secret's been revealed I think
I think the show is too different it's
it's going to it's got to be it's got to
be an evolution rather than
even a continuation it
I mean it's it's got to be a different
show because there's so much time think
about the difference between the first
episode of sg1 and the last episode of
sqr the different
it's been 15 years since then
20 years really
it's the 30th Anniversary next year of
the movie coming out wow
that's how long is it so I mean I just
don't I just don't see that it it can
but we're saying we keep the cannon like
she just followed up with another
question
yeah I would say
yeah do we I think the Canon's gonna be
it cannot be it's got to be a
continuation in that sense I'm doing a
video from the week because there's been
a lot of YouTube videos knocking around
that since that deadline story that a
lot of people are saying this is going
to be a remake of Stargate and it's not
but I have spoken to a couple of people
and I've got a bit of information about
that but um just to just to reiterate
it's not
there is going to be a continuation but
I don't think it can be a straight
situation like Star Trek the Next
Generation was
it's got it's going to be a different
show it's got to be
um for it to make sense I think but I
think yeah to a point and they need they
need to I mean
they need to find a balance between
progressing the show and still keeping
like the base feel underneath like
I think that they've got to figure out
what's core in there which is why we
started talking about that briefly early
about the humor
grounded in some sort of realism
um
it's got to be really character based if
you think about it stargate's really all
about the characters the technology is
just the uh
it's just the medium for them to explore
their character stories in because
really when it all comes down to it it
all it it all comes back essentially
basically even every episode it all
comes back to uh
how people or you know entities deal
with each other at the end of the day
it's always all about that
I think that'll maintain enough of the
actual Stargate feel and throw in a
little bit of sarcasm and I think so
that'll get us most of the way there at
least
go on horse you just said action
if I have to complain about one thing in
Stargate
one thing
every P90 just goes
and I don't think they ever they're
worse aims than Stormtroopers but
apparently they're their best AIMS in
the world because this is not how you
aim a damn P90 it's never how you've
ever aimed a P90 and that's never how
you will aim a P90
let I wouldn't mind all of them going to
train with Terran Tactical for a week
not not a whole month but just a week
before shooting just a quick question
just so the writers and directors know
what the hell to do on set
have you ever fired a P90
yes so you can do it one-handed you know
you can no no
the P90 all them all the mechanism is
right in the back here it's one of the
most accurate weapons on the planet so
you can point and shoot the peanut you
shouldn't you should use two hands and
you're obviously far more accurate but
the P90
looks doing that I think everybody else
teal might be able to do that everybody
else in the military they still wouldn't
just be doing this though they're
military trained they're looking through
their sights
it's different yeah someone that much
more SEAL Team Six less Rambo
yeah but it look cool and he didn't and
you wouldn't obviously wouldn't be there
with his shirt off and you know with a
constantly wearing thingy shirts and
just because it's going to show off his
guns come on
foreign
I don't know about that but anyway yeah
I love the peanuts great weapon I love
anything that holds 100 rounds
so thank you very much
um but okay
um
yeah anyway I lost my complete train I
thought where were we
are we going are we finished now are we
done
I think so I think that's up to you I
think that's where we were
unless you want to sit and listen to me
and Harris talk about the potential
final four or fantastic forecasting that
dropped yesterday evening yes because I
owe you two in a while
who who they say your name
um the uh the rumored finalist is Adam
Driver as Reed Richards Margot Robbia
Sue storm
um I still got my notes from wrestling
um as
um
um any storm and who say that one more
time
Paul meskel Mezcal Mescal oh okay yeah
they got they got him for Johnny and
then they got David Diggs for Ben Grimm
I like I like defeat digs a lot for that
after sun uh and and not much else
honestly uh but he's good he's good well
I looked him up he's done a [__] ton of
Voice work
s
oh yeah yeah let's try to find him oh
there we go all right both he and Paul
are um have a lot of stage background
too they both wanted Stage Works
yeah I'm telling you now Adam Driver not
a chance
actually I didn't hear you say Paul
because he's the one he's the one that's
actually closest to being locked down
it's the other three that are more iffy
oh yeah no Adam Driver
because I I do not believe that for a
second I did recently hear a rumor that
they're trying to get Adam Driver for
the Harry Potter series
that I could see what was he gonna be
like young Snape or something that was
one rumor
looks like that would be perfect you can
do a British accent though
but I can't see Adam Driver in Marvel I
just can't but hey maybe they've got
maybe Disney you've got him on a on some
sort of deal I'm just gonna give him
something so if he's not reading to make
him Victor Von Doom please that I could
see that
do you know what I actually genuinely
think about those names who've just
thrown out there yeah I don't think
Marvel want to make a good Fantastic
Four movie
I think they're actually determined not
to
so
um why would you say that from those
four just Margot Robbie that is awful
I missed Marco Robbie is Margot Robbie
gonna play
Invisible Woman
they don't want to make a good
profession I think she's the only one
that I think the other three actually
make the exact opposite argument for
that Adam Driver Paul muscal or two
oscar-nominated actors that are both
very very like pertinent with their
choices besides 65 for Adam Driver but
he made that with Sam Raimi because they
were having fun they he chooses things
very particularly Paul Muscat uses
things very particularly and David Diggs
I mean he's just a talent if you've ever
heard or seen him perform he's a talent
I think that's a fantastic cast Margo
she's cool
but that that could she's your argument
for oh they just want to kind of hurt
for me she's the weakest Choice out of
those I agree I agree there's there's
better blind chicks out there like she's
excellent in certain things but
I don't see her give us Jody Comer Jody
Comer and Adam Driver together would be
perfect I'm just for the coma come on I
just can't I just can't see that those
names you just think about well but I
tell you what MCU used to be really good
at throwing things like that out and
making it work yeah
um I don't think they're very good at
that anymore so let's see if they can
get back to their route to actually
start doing it or at least they weren't
phase four forever everything I've seen
and heard says like he's in there with
whip and chair handling business again
because he needs to yes all right guys
look it's been an hour and a half I
don't want to get into a big long thing
but that we let's we'll talk about this
another time but um but yeah let's see
if we can I'll have a sniff around and
see if I can see how solid those names
actually are or whether they're just
again just rumors because I'd be shocked
I will give away
my left nut if that's true
I was very very particular on that
conversation you're like should we get
tattoos I was like
because I believe we'll get there and I
don't want a tattoo
see I don't believe we will so I don't
mind
Shelly are you feeling anything better
[__] stamp like a tear tattoo he's
gonna have like some weird thing
crawling down his neck or something who
knows in a couple hundred thousand
people I'm only having it running from
here down to the bottom of the sternum
there you go I'm having a scientists
um your Sci-Fi TV movie channel like on
the bottom of my foot or something
was my penis and I thought don't say
that well now you're putting out there
watch out like real quick
clip it clip it clip it flip it just
real quick I want to address Mark
directly right now Marvel is set up to
just pull push through and drop a
humongous presentation at sdcc
so and one of the things they could do
for that is announce the Fantastic
forecast
to announce Disney had booked a load of
stuff for the San Diego Comic-Con and
they've canceled almost all of it
I was about to say if zag does that
they're the same same boat as
s-g-a-u-1 Stargate whatever uh it like
yeah you can have actors go up there and
do all that
yeah orifice tap for 50k
all I can tell you is that Warner
Brothers
out there he didn't have any actors or
actresses out there with him he was just
him on stage just dropping cinematic
bombs on us and it was good that's true
uh yeah
yeah exactly he can do that again he
won't have to worry about crossing any
or trying to force anyone to cross any
lines or anything
and get it
at Disney right now you know we had the
big rework of the Marvel slate for the
next couple of years last year and and
there's sort of a lot of things are
rejumbled
expect things to be even more oh I mean
we're gonna have a lot less Marvel
put it out oh yeah
yeah well that was that was that was the
thing before the writers strike that
Kevin feiget already announced that they
were going to do maybe three shows and
two movies a year maximum
it's going to go even further than it's
been currently announced anyway but we
we won't get major at the moment San
Diego Comic-Con is is looking less than
like we're gonna have any major
announcements the main thing is there
seems to be this this same argument I
keep hearing from people I'm talking to
is that big studios are Running Scared
at the moment they they know they look
like wankers and they don't want to look
any more like one because and so the the
problem with that is San Diego Comic-Con
it could backfire really badly if they
start announcing things
I think I'll be really really careful
what they announced but Warner Brothers
had loads of stuff particularly DC stuff
they were planning to do for San Diego
Comic-Con you know because we've had
um gun in place for the other fella and
they've been real they've they've really
gone out with a chop and block we've
announced a lot of things been canceled
they wanted to really throw out and
actually start putting some meat on the
bones of some of the things that they
have sort of like drip fed us you know
with the Superman and us they were going
to announce craploads of San Diego
Comic-Con they had like three convention
rooms booked for like two days solid and
all and they've canceled it all
wow
nope so um the the their
um Presence at San Diego Comic-Con is
going to be like 10 of what it was and
Disney apparently have gone going the
same way
so at the moment can be a ball Fest
unless something changes that's funny
you say boyfriend people talk about
Andor in the chat
andal was great I literally the comment
I made in the chat with andor's legit
great even with lyrics it was great
television it was just crap Star Wars
like literally George hired Empire
Strikes Back hired a different director
to elevate Star Wars I don't think
elevating Star Wars will ever not be
Star Wars I understand it not being like
focally directed towards children uh the
same way most other Star Wars may be but
there's Star Wars resistance for that do
you see Star Wars resistance
no exactly so I don't think that I don't
think the same people that complain
about Andor should be saying anything if
they're not watching every single bit of
children's media Andor was beautiful
beautiful and I will fight for it
forever
oh there's my guy Justin hey what's
going on buddy
um oh I won't deny that as gorgeously
produced gorgeously written gorgeously
active
it's
it's doesn't have the feel of Star Wars
it doesn't feel no no no no no no no no
sorry it did it really did feel like
Star Wars because loads of star all of
Star Wars is really boring and we'll
leave it there
[Laughter]
we're going to do a couple of these
Stargate videos because we genuinely do
believe that we're going to be getting
something announced really soon so this
week we talked about should it be a
thing guys I'd love you to get in the
comments if there are other questions on
the Stargate bigger Universe you want us
to debate he wants to get our teeth
stuck into I'd love for you to let us
know I will put a comment on the
Community page as well and invite you
guys to think of other things that we
could discuss and tear apart
um live as only we can and then we'll
wander around and start talking about
Willy's I've drawn on people's faces and
things because
that's just what we do I don't know why
it happens I generally try not to but um
it's always
I hate that the last two sentences you
just said went the way you did because
mentally I've I'm still on uh Shelley
commenting about orifice is in the
comments and and people are like what
the hell are you talking about orifice
is she explained it later but it cracked
me up the other day when you posted the
fedcon picture of RDA and uh uh Amanda
Tapping out there and then Shelley was
like I don't know what that is but
that's one beautiful orifice
it's not looking at my phone for five
minutes just cracking up
tear it up and then something about
Willie's right after so tearing it up
and then putting Willies and things the
orifice mindset needs to just keep
moving
we'll never never move away from the
orifice yeah guys thank you so so much
it's been a brilliant chat
um Matt has been sat too long he's now
sleepy
my back is killing
I mean so much pain oh yeah you're
building dumplings weren't you I need to
say you're trying to adjust myself
oh God
we're all didn't we make
all right guys thank you so so much I
really appreciate it now stop I think
we're ending the stream now Harris
nobody
get good chairs for your back that's all
good oh yeah I started the last one oh
no it's not it's not the chair I built a
trampoline
and I'm in pain for it
I've got a bad back as well but I'm not
telling you why so tune in next week to
find out why I've got a bad back okay
guys thank you so so much we will leave
it there we will be back next week if
anybody's got some brilliant ideas don't
forget to go and look at our Brad Reich
for Stargate
um thing I haven't looked for a couple
of days but last time we were pushing 4
000 signatures so let's get that shared
as well I will push that out again in
the next few days
um
so yeah that would be five this would be
awesome so we want we want Brad right to
be involved for Stargate in some way the
guy is actually I mean look I message
him about this video and he actually
bothered replying the guy's a legend he
does that it's not just me he does that
for anybody if you want to say anything
about star star game you know he will
some guy was moaning about the
relationship between Daniel and um Jack
O'Neill on on what on my Twitter stream
the other day
um I ever heard this thing of shippers
you guys ever heard that before I never
heard of it yeah but anyway until
recently now I can't stop hearing it now
um but anyway there was shipping there
was one true pair
um
about these things that go over my head
but anyway like if me and you were
shipped we'd be jacked or or May
[Laughter]
but he did sort of say look this is why
we did it and the guy went well you
answered my question and then it just
went okay
anyway guys thank you so so much let's
let's end it I will speak to you all the
week and then guys if you've got any
ideas what we want to do next week throw
them across beautiful
in our office
[Music]